The general message that I want you to take away from this discussion is that
features and information are two different things.
What you really want out of your data is information.
You want to be able to draw conclusions and have insights.
And that's not,
strictly speaking, the same thing as having lots of features in the data.
So the feature is the actual number or characteristic of
a particular data point that's attempting to access information.
But it's not exactly the same as information itself.
So for example, it's a little bit like the difference between the quantity of
something and the quality.
If you have lots of feature you might have a lot of quantity of data.
The quality of those features is the information content.
So, in general, what you want is the bare minimum number of
features that it takes to give you as much information as possible.
If there's a feature present that isn't giving you information,
you want to get rid of it, because it can cause all of those problems that we
were talking about in the last video.